i enjoyed uh watching him work out uh at
the combine and then the stories uh
surrounding him
um caused me to just say let's let's get
him on and uh let's uh let's uh you've
gotta have on a guy whose nickname is
beef because his last name is jergens
and he's beef jerky of uh of nebraska
born and raised in nebraska played for
his hometown nebraska cornhuskers and
he's uh
one of the top linemen of all in the
draft if not the top center available in
the draft coming up later on this month
he is cam jergens how are you cam
i'm doing good how are you guys doing
i'm doing fine uh did i get that entire
introduction correct that is anything um
off on that camera oh sounds great
sounds great okay uh how did you walk me
through how you got the nickname of beef
camp
uh pretty much when i got to nebraska uh
i mean i kind of had a lot of nicknames
growing up uh
when i got here
i guess
during nil they started doing like a
branding series
and basically they asked like hey we
want to make a logo for you and do some
stuff and like hey what what nicknames
like do you want a nickname or slogan
i'm like shoot everybody calls me beef
jerky you know so i did that and
kind of grew up on a cattle farm so it
kind of it makes sense um so i loved it
okay and is it true cam that you have
your own line of beef jerky called beef
jerky is that true
yeah yeah so during an hour started
making some stuff and a bunch of local
lockers reached out sent me jerky and i
started you know working with them and i
got a got my own beef jerky jerky
when you say you work with them you're
talking about sampling the product
making sure it tastes appropriate to put
your nickname on it so what you're
saying yeah exactly okay what does it
taste like what does it what do you got
for me
cam oh it's it's good you have to check
it out uh we'll send some in but i'm
doing it filling it on beefjergy.com
okay yeah it's it's pretty good so far
i'm trying to you know starting small
building up and it's just something fun
to do you know i kind of kind of grew up
we we deer hunted and we make our own
jerky from that so it's always something
that's been really you know interesting
to me
yes as distributed by cam jergens i see
the the packaging right there um
okay beef jerky
so do you want to like take this on
shark tank or something like that cam
would you do that uh you know we'll see
where it goes uh come on i'm not sure
but i mean i'd love to expand and get
bigger but right now it's just kind of
donut online and then small local places
in uh around the area in nebraska okay
well you don't have to send any to me i
mean you're not yet a professional i i
can't i mean normally i get into this
business to get free stuff
certainly not just for me but for for my
guys here
where can we where can people get your
product
we're talking about
i got a i got a website beefjergy.com
bfjurgy.com
correct yes sir yeah it's uh i had a
teammate
last year uh matt tichtman he he kind of
helped set up a website with me and it's
kind of been a fun project for us i love
it rich he's got a limited time offer
five packs for 35
wow at beefjerky.com okay i i'm not
really a consumer of beef jerky a lot is
that a that that's a that's a good deal
that's a good deal that's a real good
deal that's a real good deal
cam
yeah it's a great deal
come on sell me on it man
you don't have to be a consumer of beef
jerky to you know enjoy it because it's
a really good product so i think you you
know if you try it out people enjoy it
you've got all kinds of merch rich uh
sweatshirts polos hats he's got a beer
koozie
he's got the full package sodium i tell
you you know nebraska fans are crazy you
know there's people all over the state
all over the country and you know when
uh when the husker players you know make
their own line uh it's really cool
seeing the support you know a lot of
people bought stuff during the year and
you know all over the country uh
it's it's pretty unique with uh nebraska
fan base okay academic all-american so
did you take uh marketing did you take
economics or business anything uh at
nebraska no i'm actually a exercise
nutrition science major so i'm kind of
learning as we go when we you know went
through this process
mm-hmm okay now let's talk about your
game uh
uh the word nasty comes up a lot do you
hear that a lot in terms of your game oh
yeah yeah and you know
i think it's hard to be a good old lyman
if you don't have a little grit and you
don't have a little edge to you so i
think that's something i really pride
myself in and you know i'm trying to be
the toughest guy in the field every time
i step out there okay
how many people did you piss off over
this uh entire period when you're
playing and against fellow prospects and
things like that during that this i say
probably too much to worry about
[Laughter]
too much to worry about
okay i love that what's the number by
which you pass that uh that fault line
of uh of no longer caring about how many
people you've pissed off
i don't know i don't think you gotta
yeah i mean football you you can't care
about people you piss off i mean it's
kind of the
you know it's kind of the job of a
lineman you gotta you know get dirty you
gotta be in the trenches there and you
don't get no love no no glory but that's
that's kind of the job for us and i you
know it kind of fits my mold i think
didn't you piss off a ton of people uh
at the senior poll cam did i see some
video of us oh so i didn't go to the
senior boy yeah i was actually you know
i'm an underclassman so i wasn't allowed
there so that was somebody else that i
saw okay and so when you're when you
when you actually get into it though
what is your your sense when when uh
when it's your job to protect when it's
your job
to make sure the play is handled
appropriately pre-snap walk me through
that for you cam
yeah especially the center position you
know you're asked a lot you got to make
sure
like you're confident in what you're
doing you're calling the plays or
protections um you know you're setting
the point you know whatever the play is
and you got to make sure you're setting
the tone because you know the guys
around us in the whole line i got to
make sure i'm doing my job so they have
confidence in me when i'm making my
points where i'm making my calls
and at the end of the day we make sure
no one touches our quarterback you know
you know that's our guy back there so
got to keep him clean and you know in
the run game pass game it's all the same
you got you know you're trying to put
guys on the ground you're trying to you
know set the tone because that's kind of
where the games won and lost a lot of
times
uh is it true you already met with the
broncos you took a visit there
cam yeah i just took a a top 30 visit
there a few days ago okay so what what
did you glean from that did you meet
coach hackett who walked me through your
your process there
cam yeah i got to meet everybody there
and it was it was really cool meeting
all the new coaches uh coach hackett's
got a lot of energy i love meeting with
him and the the oc and coach barry like
it was it was really cool time those
those top 30 visits are fun but it's
just kind of in and out it's real quick
um so what's the craziest question
you've been asked during this entire uh
process this entire
uh talent evaluation season cam jergens
uh i don't know if i'd have any you know
crazy questions i guess i had a had a
pretty long handshake with coach brabel
when i first met him walking in you know
questioning me and it was just like uh
who can squeeze each other's hand harder
for like a minute straight just staring
at each other so that was a nice little
fun introduction into that meeting but
otherwise not any like super crazy
questions
but it's kind of been all fun during
this process mean
meeting all the coaches and getting to
see people
it's kind of it's been really
eye-opening you know i i think the
coolest part was like i went into the
the dolphins i see dan moreno in there
i'm like man that's that's pretty pretty
cool now did you know him from football
or uh aceventure a pet detective let's
be honest cam come on now oh football oh
okay all right you're a football guy
that didn't make it to the cow farm ace
ventura didn't make it to the california
in nebraska you didn't see that there no
no it didn't okay you got to see it
you'll love it um okay so let me get
back to the variable thing i just had
him on yesterday i wish i'd known this
before he had he was here what are you
talking about like you you sensed he was
testing you for how long you were going
to grip
and and yeah i guess i i think you can
you know you can sense a lot from a man
that was how he shakes someone's hand
right look him right now look him right
in the eye yeah you got to be you got to
be formal and you got to look in the eye
you got to give a firm grip for sure
and so at one point you thought he's not
letting go of my hand i need to do
something about this like you didn't
like walk me through that give me what
do you mean
yeah i think i don't know i mean you got
to make sure you're shaking your hand
longer than the other guy is it's kind
of like a test you know who's going to
stop shaking their hand first
okay
all right i'd love to see you play for
tennessee then and see how that goes
you know i would love that i bet so what
are you doing draft night what's draft
night for you like cam
uh i'm just gonna have it at the at the
house back in my uh hometown you know
small family get together we'll see i
feel it's you know that's a stressful
situation you want to have people that
care about you around there but you
don't want it too big
are you catering are you catering
yourself you're gonna have your your
product out there on draft night
yeah we'll have some jerky there uh you
know my brother he's actually got uh
he's got a food truck he he has some he
has a really good barbecue food truck so
he's gonna be making food for us that
night all right
have you been on will compton's pod yet
have you done that
no i haven't i need to uh they came to
nebraska for uh one of our games last
year so i got to get on the bus but i
didn't do a podcast with them but yeah
that's
that's a fun podcast to listen to well
if you if you go to tennessee i mean
that's it i mean that that would be it i
mean that you'd you'd have to be on the
bus there for sure yeah i feel like if i
i'm sure if i get drafted there that's i
mean i'm making it on the pod for sure i
can't believe i beat will compton to the
punch and having a nebraska cornhusker
top prospect in the draft on on a
program
that's fantastic yeah i know we get we
got to get after him about about that
one you know what i just think um we
should just let just let it sit out
there and and see how it how it
marinates you know we can do that um all
right cam thank you for the call good
luck to you let's do this uh when you
land somewhere let's talk
let's talk a little bit good look
forward to it congratulations on
everything that happened at nebraska on
your your growing beef jerky business
and um and and beyond i look forward to
seeing where you land on draft night
thank you you guys have a good one you
got it that's cam jergens everybody
nebraska cornhusker center hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here